let's hear from a few more people we do
calls on the Friday show via Discord
which you can find at davidpackman.com
slash Discord I want to go next to
George from Virginia George from
Virginia welcome to the program what's
on your mind today
George you're on the air
George you probably have the wrong audio
device selected if you can fix that we
will then be able to hear you
all right George well uh unfortunately
the technical issues plaguing George
let's go to Dustin from Hamilton now
Hamilton could be I don't know how many
states have a Hamilton I think there's
even a Hamilton there's there's probably
a Hamilton in Canada as well so Dustin
from Hamilton I don't know where you're
really calling from uh maybe you can
tell us what's on your mind today
okay Dustin from Hamilton are you there
Dustin you've now muted yourself please
unmute yourself
all right two in a row folks this is not
common let's go to Freddy from the Bay
Area California I will soon be in the
Bay Area in California it's going to be
a beautiful thing Freddy what's going on
all right hey David thanks for taking my
call
um
I was I don't know if you talked about
this already I kind of joined in a
little late okay but I was just
wondering your thoughts on the
um George Santos indictments oh yeah on
the Wednesday show we talked about it
pretty extensively I have to tell you I
am not the type of person to take
pleasure in the failings of others but I
am delighted by the arrest of George
Santos because not because I go around
saying I don't like your politics and
you lied so you should get arrested not
because of that but because there's so
much evidence against the guy exactly
his actions warrants criminal charges
and now he's going to have to deal with
it and maybe he'll end up getting kicked
out of Congress who knows
right that's that's what I'm thinking
like what do you think is going to
happen I mean do you think hopefully he
actually you know gets in trouble for
this and doesn't actually be able to
stay in congress absolutely and you know
the truth is with this guy
people are already talking about prison
time I don't even care about that I just
want them out of the House of
Representatives it seems like it would
be a moral wrong for him to have gotten
away with what he got away with and to
serve out his full two years I want him
to suffer the humiliation of being
kicked out of Congress early and by the
way I don't have in front of me what the
rules are about how you qualify for like
the retirement packages from Congress
which are fantastic my thought is if he
doesn't make it a full term he doesn't
get any of them which would also be a
really great thing
right yeah he doesn't deserve any of
that it's just the way that he flaunts
around it's almost like he likes the
attention and it's going out going to
parties and stuff it's just like come on
he doesn't deserve any of that the guy's
pathetic he adds nothing he adds nothing
he really is Freddie can I ask you a Bay
Area question and get your advice
sure so when I'm gonna be out there I am
going to basically have commitments
partially in San Francisco and partially
in Santa Cruz so my idea was to stay
somewhere roughly in between and so I
only have to drive half the distance
when I go to one or the other people
have said to me maybe look at Palo Alto
or Mountain View or whatever that seems
to be a little closer to San Francisco
than Santa Cruz but my question to you
is where
would be a convenient place to stay with
a nice walkable downtown with some
hipster coffee shops and the whole thing
that would be relatively convenient to
both cities what do you recommend okay
so Palo Alto yes that area there's a
town called Saratoga okay right when you
go up and over the Santa Cruz mountains
yes you're closer to Santa Cruz but you
want to be closer to Santa Cruz right
now everywhere closer to San Francisco
uh no Saratoga I used to have to stay
there I was bringing my dog to a vet up
there actually but okay talking about
little hipster places coffee good little
places to eat small quaint very nice
good little hotels that's a great place
little parks to go walking I have I have
an 18 month old little girl and she was
probably eight months old at the time
and we were bringing her in the stroller
of these little parks and stuff
fantastic Place Saratoga I'm down in
Monterey right now so I'm gonna look
into that Freddy that sounds good that
sounds very good I'm going to check into
that I appreciate the advice
yeah no problem at all all right there's
Freddie from the Bay Area beautiful
phone call folks I have to say
absolutely fantastic